does this add up a school district in
Pennsylvania thinks that feelings should
be taught in math class but not
everybody is on board under the proposal
lessons for kindergarteners through
fifth grade would include social
emotional learning elements a school
board member there claims that workbooks
ask questions like are you understanding
how other people feel she spoke out
about it on Fox and Friends
when we first were shown this program I
saw that had social emotional learning
and my first thought is what does that
have what do feelings have to do with
math did the program just started last
year so there isn't any data to see if
it's really a good system to use we
should be creating critical thinkers
that are getting in the math mindset not
what am I feeling today or what is
someone else feeling but is this really
going to get them ahead schools Across
America are failing students with
reading and math proficiency at historic
lows 23 Baltimore schools report no math
proficiency and 53 Illinois high schools
fail to achieve grade level Proficiency
in math
Greg do you
think that they're
so this is just being considered let's
be clear about that
do you think that in the post-pandemic
world considering all of the challenges
that we've talked about for students the
mental health crises that it's that
ridiculous of an idea to consider social
emotional learning being part of math
lessons
yes it's ridiculous you've shocked me I
know I know and there are three women on
this table so I want to back up and
explain what math is
math math is the language of the
universe you don't want to mess with it
it's the strangest thing in existence
because you can't tell whether you
invented it or it was a discovery like
what was Matt always hearing you oh my
goodness two plus two equals four or did
somebody actually create it why do you
have a fondness for it why is it in
everything you see this this is and my
point is this it's the secret to life
itself there are what 7 000 languages
right the reason why we have war and and
well the reason why we have war is
differences in languages we can't
communicate with each other math is the
only universal language it's the only
language that the Germans in the French
the language of love that is true we'll
talk about that later in my hot tub
please but this is the only language
that cuts across all people and the woke
want to take that apart they want to
take the universality of math and and
balkanize it so somebody says like yeah
you may think two plus two equals four
but four hurt my feelings so I'm going
to say that two plus two equals five
minus one which is kind of like four but
it takes longer but I just don't like
saying the word four because well when I
was when I was four I burned my finger
around a toaster and I you know I just
can't say four anymore we do have
feelings about math but we all have to
have the universality of those feelings
right if
what do you think of Greg's thesis
I actually like it a lot
oh because math can be you that's a
place where you can be free from having
to have feelings everything is about
feelings and there is yes
freedom in math math does give you
freedom and that's why one of the
reasons people are so excited about stem
education for both genders yeah or all
genders whatever but the the thing
that's really incredible is how
on Newsroom we did the story about how
Baltimore schools they have no child in
the eighth grade that can is proficient
in math then we do it like a story two
days later about Chicago and the Chicago
Public School sends us a statement
saying we just want to make sure it's
very clear to you that our test results
are right in line with all the other
major cities in America like okay that's
not a great defense guys it's just not a
good defense and math can be one of
those places where it can Propel you
into Great Heights you can get
independence from knowing math well
enough or even to Greater Heights if you
know it very well so I don't think
there's any need to bring feelings into
it feelings isn't everything else read a
book that's where you get feelings
not a math book no I agree with that
first of all whose idea was this why are
they implementing it they don't say who
who they're helping why are they
proposing it they've got no data none of
it makes sense and if you want feelings
I get it maybe English maybe reading and
all that other stuff maybe even history
but math math is the only objective
thing that we've got there's no there's
no it's not subjective it's an objective
test deal with it you can't influence it
you can't change it you can't wake it or
bury it or anything else plus now think
about it parents now have to go to the
school board meetings I don't want
feelings in my child's math class these
four parents I got to work harder than
they've ever worked their whole life I
know it's like another part-time job
yeah
you guys are clearly trying to feminize
math and I won't stand for it when an
architect builds a bridge what's more
important how the architect
feels about the bridge or what he knows
about the bridge I'm not driving over a
bridge that was engineered by a guy that
was in touch with his feelings I'm
driving over a bridge if I don't want to
die engineered by a Brit or a German
who's never cried
that is a sturdy Bridge
do you want me to tell you what I really
feel about this though I think it has to
do with covet and Equity because all of
these test scores went down and so they
have to lower the standards to get the
test scores back up Black and Hispanic
students regressed even worse than white
students during the pandemic a lot of
it's economic but they're also trying to
close the racial achievement Gap and
again that's why they're lowering the
standards or
they're trying to feminize math
not only that I just like is what a
sexist would say exactly oh you forgot
to lead with that so people will be con
but you're finishing strong that's what
a sexist would say hi when are Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now